I asked for the wine but no way I mean
five because your teen and I'm a teacher
we can't have the title teachers corrupt
young teens that's a different kind of
website
hi I'm Madison and I'm a senior in high
school hey my name is Ted and I'm a
teacher
my name is Salani and I'm a science
teacher hi my name is Bryant and I'm a
team we're going to swap sag oh yeah I
know what you would have a bad kid I
feel like they're gonna be like apples
and stuff I feel like you have like a
very refined palate I feel like
something like to have wine that the one
part you got that there's gonna be a lot
of sugary processed foods how could you
tell
they usually have like a full meal as
well a student 700 sacks is not sure
what exactly will be seeing but let's
get to snack it let's do it
I have raspberries and strawberries I
would just put this in like a plastic
bag and then like eat it in the car I
chose Talkies because most of the time
I'm actually not awake in the morning
usually I like a fool like fresh mango
yes a wool you have time for that I
chose these roasted seaweed snacks
because the morning I like to eat
something white - yeah definitely can
eat some strawberries these are a lot of
time that's a lie I don't eat a lot of
dried fruit my tastes like candy thank
you for reminding me of how much I love
it
you're welcome I am a teacher I am
really not surprised that she looks like
a fresh fruit no a Cheeto in the Dorito
had my gun illicit affair in Atlantic
City one weekend I would definitely swap
this at home I would eat this anyways
perfect what I swap this neck absolutely
not
I say that as I'm still eating them I
would swap this back
I do enjoy seeing no this is friggin I
wanna do next one alright so let's talk
more about lunchtime snacks
these are all selecting my study snack I
chose cheese and crackers it's a protein
you got some fats and grains
okay I chose mulches fruit snacks what
do they mean well no pork well like what
Oh pigskin I always tend to scoot right
on past the normal natural food and go
right for the artificial process how
many are there like four in the packet
all the crinkling noises mmm
I enjoy it but um you know I'm a guy on
the loop what what
so you just whip out like your tractors
and she's and like all right hurtling
let's go I would have this uh party to
actually hit everything at a party
everything elephant and this was would
be like a nice like once a year snap for
me once a year yeah I'm gonna keep my do
I am eight this entire bag of twenty
fifteen seconds on the go [ __ ] is very
popular in like you know Asian culture
so people would call me out on this a
lot feeling a little peckish what do I
go for sugary sweet almonds I brought
goldfish
it's a classic cheese snack and I drink
a lot of wine so this definitely goes oh
yeah here let me help you with this man
yeah really salty to you I'm just like
like in my own world of disgust right
now I don't hate it hate is this
drilling warden this is too salty I can
take it oh my god okay Wow definitely
sticking with mine yeah I'm definitely
go stick with this but I did like your
other snows and we're really nice to go
back to my childhood with the goldfish
and the fruit snacks um and your best
friend and my new best friend Brian
they're definitely different
I'm very sweet and you're very salty no
not a personality though you're very
sweet personally people looking back at
the past I can respect it and but still
happy to be here in the present but I'm
always willing to try new stuff you know
I definitely I'm gonna stick with my
snacks if she was one of my fellow
teachers I'd be trying to steal song
yeah I'm still in my golden years so I
can enjoy toxic
[Laughter]